Gary just took a DNA test because he's
trying to trace his family tree he's
chasing this family of his I don't know
they don't want to know him yeah they're
trying to hide with him you can tell you
exactly what it is but it turns out he's
like barely Italian what yeah I'm
central it says that I'm 70% southeast
European but you're not Italian then
it's everything that's right next to
Italy it's Lou that's right it's the
other side of the Adriatic Sea but like
it's a DNA test that I took for like 50
bucks so who the [ __ ] knows how reliable
how do you feel that you're not Italian
any news on all this is this the part
where I dropped to my knees and I go oh
my god Who am I don't know but Gary
Italy was not listed on the countries
that you're from I mean there is not one
mention of Italy I'll read it to you I
they said because he seems to still be
confused the tests say he is 67 percent
European specifically from Southeast
Europe their definition of what
countries that includes is Albania
Bosnia Herzegovina Kersey Maggie yeah
Macedonia every one of those when
Yugoslavia broke up it went to like 12
different countries so your Yugoslavia
there maybe Gary also learned he's 11%
Sephardic Jew Wow the test believes his
Sephardic DNA comes from the Jewish
Diaspora
Gary Papa do you realize you're not
Italian annoy a Lahan your mother hello
by the way I want to be referred to as
hi um Dell'Abate Gary is 21% middle
eastern 18% is from what is called Asia
Minor which is mostly western Turkey I
thought he was Turkish yeah yeah I know
you do 3% of that is from the West
Middle East like Egypt Jordan Israel and
Lebanon 1% of that is from North Africa
I love that you're not Italian but you
appropriated the Italian name Dell'Abate
yes della Botstein originally